(dramatic music)
(static buzzing)
- Okay everyone, greetings.
Happy, happy Thursday.
This is really a day
when I would have loved
to take you outside.
And I'm feeling more constrained
than usual by the camera,
which is making me stay inside.
I try not to be constrained
by the camera at all
but there are a few things that I can't do
because of the camera
and one of them is like,
call out your names when I
know that you're my class
and you're not sitting here.
Like which I would totally be doing
right now with some of you,
but I can't because then like,
you know, 3 million people would email-
Oh, one of them just showed up. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
Okay, good.
Okay, here's what I wanna talk about.
I wanna talk about time.
So if we were outside, I
could do this with the trees,
and I could talk about how
the seasons are changing
and the years go by
and each year is a bit
different than the one before.
And some things remind
us of previous years,
like the leaves changing, right?
I could talk about time
because the argument
that I want you to get
from this lecture is that
history doesn't actually end.
And if we can get that down,
a whole lot of the politics
of the 21st century
we'll see will make
more sense than it does.
History doesn't actually end.
Okay, why am I starting so grandly?
I'm starting so grandly because
I really think it's the case
that the decline in history
and the decline in the humanities
in the last 30 years
have a great deal to do
with the collapse of democracy
and the rise of other forms of politics.
I really think it's the case that
the absence of bearings in the past
mean that people are easier to manipulate.
Or at the very least, the
absence of bearings in the past
opens the way for myth-makers
who focus on the innocence of our group
as the only thing which
matters from the past.
I think also the idea that
history has come to an end
is a way of flattening or
stultifying the imagination.
If history is over,
then this is the one thing
that you just kinda get,
and there's not any point
practicing your imagination
and trying to imagine how,
trying to work with your own minds
to see how things might be different.
There are, you know, you are-
Don't worry, I'm gonna talk about Ukraine
within like three minutes.
You can set a timer if you want.
But, you have already been
exposed to various kinds of ideas
about how history comes to an
end in your lifetime, right?
So one version of how
history comes to an end
is nationalism, right?
So everybody's sorted
out into their own place
and like we're all ethnically homogeneous,
and then history comes to an end, right?
That version of history coming to an end
is implied in any notion which says
the outsiders are the problem
and only if we had fewer
of them and it was just us,
then everything would be fine, right?
History would come to an end.
This hasn't really been
a class about nationalism
but if you think way
back to the beginning,
there's implicit in the
idea of ethnic nationalism,
is the idea, is the assumption that,
well, once we finally have our own state
and it's just our people,
then history comes to an end.
All tensions will come to an
end, history will be over.
Another version of
history coming to an end
is consumerism, right?
Fundamentally, it's all
just Homo economicus,
there's just supply and demand.
They're just desires
that can be fulfilled.
The market will fulfill them.
History is over, right?
We're all basically the same,
it's just a matter of like getting rid
of the last few trade barriers.
History is over.
Marxism is also an idea
about the end of history.
Marxism says that there is a way
that humans are supposed to be.
We do have a kind of human nature.
Human nature has been corrupted
by the wrong form of technology.
It will be corrected by the
right form of technology.
Human nature was corrupted
when private property entered the scene.
We were alienated from ourselves.
But once we build up industry,
once we build up high technology,
the working classes will
inherit all of that,
and we'll be restored to our own nature
and everything will be fine.
And yes, history will come to an end.
Now, this is all,
okay, maybe not in three minutes,
gimme three more minutes.
I'm gonna get to Ukraine.
This is all relevant to
this larger trajectory
that we're trying to
follow in the 20th century
of how Ukraine gets treated
in the Soviet Union.
Because Leninism was a very
special form of Marxism.
Marxism says there's a special
role for the working class
in bringing history to an end.
Marxism says the working class,
because of its special place in history,
absorbs, as it were, the
suffering of everyone,
it has a special position, positionality,
which allows it to see, as it were,
objectively all the harm of capitalism.
And when the working class takes over,
all that harm will disappear.
Now, one of the problems in Marxism
is that you never know exactly
when you're supposed
to make the revolution.
If the revolution is really about
the working class
becoming big and powerful,
isn't it then just
gonna happen on its own?
If capitalism is gonna produce
more and more injustice,
then maybe there'll be
more and more alienation
and more and more workers,
and the revolution will happen on its own.
But surely the revolution is
not gonna happen on its own.
There must be somebody who does something.
And Lenin took the view that
somebody has to do something.
And he took this view which
is called volunteerism.
He took it to kind of
an interesting extreme
where Lenin argued that
actually what is needed
is a disciplined avant-garde party,
basically political experts
working in the shadows,
who know what they're doing,
who understand reality
better than the workers.
And that those people should
make a revolution happen
as soon as there's an opportunity.
Wherever there's a weak point
in the world capitalist system,
we should push on it, make a revolution.
So with Leninism, you
get this weird mixture
of determinism and volunteerism.
If there weren't Lenin,
like if Lenin had tripped
over the furniture
in one of those cafes in
Zurich and broken his neck,
or less demanding counterfactual,
if Lenin had gotten off that train
which was going to Petrograd in 1917,
and like, you know,
I don't know, got off the train.
The train left without him, I don't know.
But invent it yourself.
But if Lenin is not on
the train to Petrograd,
it's like that one guy
is not on that one train at that one time,
there is no Bolshevik Revolution
and the 20th century looks
an awful lot different.
So in that sense, you can say he's right.
Individuals certainly matter in history.
But, so there's this extreme volunteerism,
which is confirmed by experience, right?
Lenin knows that he is right,
that without him and Trotsky and Stalin
and, you know, Kamenev and Zinoviev
and a few other characters,
there wouldn't have been that revolution.
On the other hand, they believe that
all their volunteerism,
all this willfulness
is justified by their knowledge
that history has to go a certain way.
That there has to be feudalism,
capitalism, socialism.
And now that they've carried
out their willful act,
they have to balance that willful act
by pushing the Soviet Union
through these stages of history.
Because there's only one
way that history can go.
There's only one way that history can go.
And the Soviet Union is behind,
so we're just gonna have
to push it very quickly.
The consequences of this view for Ukraine
are dramatic, right?
The whole idea that there
has to be collectivization,
that agriculture has to be collectivized
is a result of the idea
that there's only one
way that history can go.
And collectivization
then is the precondition
for the famine and the death of around
4 million people in 1932 and in 1933.
You see a similar issue
with the national question itself, right?
In the national question itself,
you have the same swinging back and forth
between determinism and volunteerism.
Where on the one hand,
we are confident we know
what's gonna happen,
and therefore, because we're
confident in the 1920s,
we're gonna let the
Ukrainian writers write,
Ukrainian artists paint,
we're gonna have affirmative
action for Ukrainians
to drive them into the bureaucracy
and as loyal administrators
into the Soviet system.
We're confident that that's the way
history is going to work.
We're confident that capitalism
is gonna produce nationalism anyway,
and so, therefore, we're
gonna do it ourselves.
We will contain it and we'll channel it
and we'll sublimate it,
and it will sublimate into
loyalty to the Soviet system.
But then in the 1930s,
they lose their confidence.
And instead of being sure
that history is on their side,
Stalin shifts back into
this volunteerist mode.
What's wrong with collectivization?
What's wrong with collectivization
is that individuals are
doing the wrong thing.
Polish spies, Ukrainian nationalists,
individual records,
people who for whatever malicious reason
are trying to block by way
of their own volunteerism,
the way that history
actually has to go, right?
So the swing from
determinism to volunteerism
also helps you to understand
how they're trying to understand
or how they're dealing
with the national question.
As we get into the Second World War
with the national question,
we see a new turn.
And the new turn is possible
because the existence of the Soviet Union
is itself in question.
So during the Second World War,
Stalin and others take a much
more benign view of Ukraine.
Why did they do this?
Because the war is being fought
largely in and for Ukraine,
and they need Ukrainians to
stay loyal to the Soviet Union.
The Germans, of course,
do them an enormous favor
by exercising more Terror
in a shorter period of time
than the Soviets did,
thereby turning most people
inside the Ukrainian Soviet Republic,
back towards the Soviet Union,
at least in the sense that it
is less bad than the Germans.
So during the Second World War,
there's a lot of nostalgia.
Ukraine is called a great nation.
Bohdan Khmelnyts'kyi is characterized
as a hero of the Ukrainian past.
The simple fact that a
Ukrainian is even mentioned
as a kind of hero is striking.
Then as we've seen in the
immediate postwar period,
there's another turn
in which the way the
national question is handled
is not just by nostalgia, right?
Which is characteristic of nationalism.
It's also handled by ethnic cleansing.
It's handled by taking
right-wing nationalist solutions
and making them Soviet policy.
And not just right-wing ones,
perfectly mainstream ones
like the Ukrainian idea of
Sobornist
which means in a political context,
it means Sobornist
means all of the territory of Ukraine
inside the boundaries of
a Ukrainian state, right?
A Soborna Ukraina
is a Ukraine that contains
all the territory that
should belong to it.
That's what Stalin creates
by extending the boundaries
of Ukraine, Soviet Ukraine, to the west.
But also there are these rather
extreme right-wing solutions,
which we talked about in the last lecture
as ethnic cleansing,
where it's not just that lots of people
get deported to Siberia,
that's traditional, right?
From it's been since the 1920s,
people have been deported to Siberia.
It's not just that a quarter
of a million Ukrainians
are deported to Siberia
right after the war.
That's notable but it's
not what I'm talking about.
What I'm talking about is something else,
which is the deportation of
Poles and Jews into Poland.
Because the deportation of
Poles and the Jews into Poland
suggests that the system
no longer believes
it can assimilate everybody.
So if you're deported to Siberia,
there's a very good chance
you're going to die.
But there is also at least
the idea in principle
that your body is going to be redeemed
for the Soviet system, right?
You're gonna be a laborer
while you're there,
after 5 years or 7 or
15 or whatever it is,
you're going to come back and
you will have been reformed.
There's at least that idea.
But if you were expelled across the border
of the Soviet Union into another country,
the system's given up on you, right?
And that is an even less confident system,
an even less internationalist system,
an even more nationally-minded system
than one had in the 1930s,
as we now get into the 1940s.
This logic is extended in a way,
and, again, now I'm
recapitulating, last time,
but this logic is extended
in a way under Zhdanov
and under this logic of the two camps,
where, you know, you can
see this subtle shift
in the second half of Soviet history,
away from economic dynamism
and towards a kind of
cultural conservatism, right?
Where the economic dynamism
of Stalin, of Stalinism,
is actually over.
But no one of course can say that, right?
You can't wake up in the
morning and say that.
But the economic dynamism
has already happened.
The economic dynamism happened,
the mines have been dug,
the factories have been built,
the big cities have been built.
The countryside has been collectivized.
All those things have been done.
And then there was this war.
And now we have to think of a
new way to justify the state.
And the way to justify the
state after the Second World War
has a great deal to do with
suddenly Russian culture,
where the class war is defined.
Zhdanov defines the
class war as Us and Them,
two camps, communists, capitalists,
or as they would say, the
democracies and the capitalists,
communists and capitalists.
But what is the Us in this?
The Us in this, under Zhdanov's reasoning,
is something like the purity
of Russian culture, right?
The purity of Russian culture.
And Russian writers are now being purged
because they are quoting Charles Dickens,
or somehow they are too cosmopolitan,
to use the word of the day, right?
Cosmopolitan.
And that word, and this is something
I wanted to mention
last time but failed to,
that word in the last
few years of Stalinism,
especially from 1948 to
early 1953 when he dies,
that word cosmopolitan is very often used
as a code for Jews.
So the Stalinist reasoning takes
up a Nazi or fascist trope,
namely that, it is the
Jews who are responsible
for the permeability of culture.
It's the Jews who open up
culture to being perverted
and influenced by outside forces.
That is what they do.
And this means that,
especially after the foundation
of the state of Israel,
there's a turn in
Stalinism against the Jews.
The last national action
which was being prepared
as Stalin fell ill and died
was to be against the Jews.
And one of you asked me, and
it's an important question,
what does all this mean for
the memory of the events
that we refer to the Holocaust
and the Soviet Union?
The events that we refer
to as the Holocaust
could not be referred,
could not be defined as such
in the Soviet Union.
In fairness, it took decades for that term
to actually emerge as
important in the United States.
I mean, deep into the 1980s,
the Holocaust in the "New York Times"
still meant nuclear holocaust, right?
It's only actually fairly recently,
basically in your
lifetimes plus a few years,
in which Holocaust has the meaning
that it does to you today,
that is, the attempt at
exterminating all the Jews.
So that's just, you know,
just to keep perspective.
But in the Soviet Union,
the notion was that
the Jews who were murdered
were peaceful Soviet citizens.
And if you were a Jew and
tried to draw attention
to the fact that Jews
were murdered as Jews,
and many more of them were
murdered than other groups,
then you were treated as someone
who was a nationalist
perhaps, or a cosmopolitan.
But in any event, you
were going to be punished.
The very people who Stalin
sent to the United States
in 1943 to raise money,
Soviet Jewish activist writers,
he sent them here, Madison Square Garden,
they were in a fundraising campaign
all across the United States
precisely on the logic that
Jews are suffering under the Nazis.
Let's raise money for the Soviet Union.
Those people were then purged
and several of them were killed
on the logic that they
had stood out, (chuckling)
and that they had done something
they weren't supposed to do.
Okay, so this brings me to
the first end of history that-
So I've already given
away the game, right?
So if I don't get to the end,
you know that history doesn't actually
ever come to an end, right?
So when I talk about
these ends of history,
I'm trying to give us some perspective
on things which were
presented as ends of history.
So my first end of history is
the end of Ukrainian history.
And what I have in mind is a
kind of dialectical solution
that Nikita Khrushchev is associated with.
By dialectics,
so, I mean, for all of you,
you know, Anglo-Saxons out there
who are used to thinking
in a straight line,
the dialectic is the
idea, you know, if at all,
the dialectic is the idea that
something can persist even
as it is transformed, right?
So that things don't just
move in a straight line,
but rather something can meet
its contrary and be overcome.
And in being overcoming,
it becomes a kind of higher reality,
which preserves elements
of what it was before,
but which is nevertheless
qualitatively different.
So, right.
So you needed like a-
Okay.
Drug joke cut right out of
the lecture, right there.
Never happened. There
was no drug joke at all.
Yeah so, it didn't happen. Never happened.
I didn't make a drug joke.
That was me not making a drug joke.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so.
Okay. You needed to
wake up an hour earlier.
You need coffee.
So the example of the dialectic,
which many people will
be roughly familiar with,
would be the Marxist dialectic, right?
So the idea that
class conflict,
capitalism is both good and bad, okay?
It's both good and bad.
It's good because it
builds up the structures
that you need for socialism,
but it's bad because it
makes the workers suffer.
So if you say capitalism is bad,
that's not quite true because
in the seeds of that suffering
is the good of the revolution, right?
And the revolution is gonna maintain,
when the revolution happens,
it's gonna preserve
elements of capitalism,
but at a higher level, right?
Transformed. Okay.
So Khrushchev has a dialectical idea
about the Ukrainian nation,
which I'm going to explain
to you in just a moment.
But before I do that,
I have to say a word about church history.
The incorporation of Volhynia and Galicia,
but especially Galicia,
poses a durable challenge
to Soviet Ukraine.
Volhynia and Galicia are
these westerly districts
that had belonged to Poland,
whose citizens have been Polish citizens
in the '20s and '30s,
and who had been exposed
to many repressions
on the Polish side,
but who had not been exposed
to Soviet Terror and Soviet famine.
In Galicia, there was still
a Greek Catholic Church.
And the Greek Catholic Church,
what the Greek Catholic Church is,
you know, it's a quintessentially
Ukrainian institution.
I was at a fundraiser for the Ukrainian
Catholic University on Sunday.
Ukrainian Catholic
Church is the institution
which was founded in 1596
by the Union of Brest,
which was known as the Uniate Church
for a couple hundred years after that.
After the partitions of Poland,
the Habsburg took this
church under their wing
and they renamed it the
Greek Catholic Church.
They educated the priests,
they treated the priests
as a kind of a conduit
for enlightenment in a larger population.
So this Greek, and then
this Greek Catholic Church
especially under Metropolitan
Andrii Sheptyts'kyi,
became something like
a national institution
under the Habsburgs and
remain so under the Poles.
Sheptyts'kyi by the way is,
well, he's remembered for a
lot of very interesting things,
but one of the things
that he's remembered for
and that we ought to know
him for in this class
is that he probably rescued
more Jews during the Holocaust
than any non-diplomat.
So there were diplomats
who rescued more people,
but Sheptyts'kyi rescued more
than a hundred Jewish children
in the St. George's complex in Lviv.
He died in 1944.
He died just as Soviet
power was returning.
When the Soviets reenacts
what had been Western,
what had been Western Ukraine
is now Western Ukraine again,
what had been Poland,
they dissolved the Greek
Catholic Church in March of 1946
and they subordinate the
Greek Catholic Church
to the Russian Orthodox
Church based in Moscow.
The Greek Catholic Church
continues to exist in hiding
as they save themselves in the catacombs.
There continued to be sacraments,
there continued to be priests
until the end of the Soviet Union.
Now a striking thing
about this little incident
which I just want you to note,
is that when the Soviet Union dissolves
the Greek Catholic Church,
they do it in March of 1946,
I'm not expecting any of you
to like do the math in your head
but that's the 350th anniversary
of the Union of Brest.
No, it's not my joke.
This is on purpose
because there's something
about these round numbers
which is starting to draw the
Soviet imagination, right?
Something about these kind
of negative anniversaries.
I say negative because when it was 1596
and the Union of Brest was made,
nobody said, "Hey, in 350 years
there'll be a Soviet Union
which is gonna undo this."
It's a negative anniversary
'cause it only makes sense
looking back, right?
So in 1946, the logic was,
a mistake was made 350 years ago,
which we are now,
yes, it's weird,
which we are now going to correct.
I just wanna note this kind
of secular thinking, right?
This treatment of the past,
this non-historical treatment of the past
as a kind of source of anniversaries
where we confirm something
or where we undo something.
This hasn't been a class on Marxism
but that is not a Marxist way
of looking at history, right?
That's not a Marxist way of
looking at history at all.
It's a very conservative
way of looking at history.
Okay, so this brings me
to what Khrushchev did,
which is very interesting.
So Nikita Khrushchev
is the last leader of
the Soviet Union/Russia
who you could say really
knew something about Ukraine.
We talked about this a few lectures ago,
this phenomenon of Russian
workers who went to the Donbas.
Sorry, Russian peasants, Russian workers
working in the Donbas.
That was Khrushchev's family.
He was from, you know, as
soon as I say this, you know,
one of my TAs who shall remain
nameless, will google it,
but he was from a little place
I think called Kalinovka,
and his family went into
the Donbas and worked,
like a lot of Russian workers, right?
Then in the party, he was in Ukraine,
Soviet Ukraine, during the Terror.
He was in Soviet Ukraine
during and after the war.
His, ugh, I'm not sure
if concubine is the word
if you're a communist
but his longtime partner,
later his wife,
was a Ukrainian from
the far, far, far west,
from Vasylkiv, or Vasilkov,
which is now actually in Poland.
So she was a Lemko.
Lemkos being Ruthenian
speakers of a language
which can be seen as a
dialect of Ukrainian.
Although if you speak
Polish, it's strikingly easy
to understand Lemko dialect of Ukrainian.
So she was a Lemko.
There were the Lemkos,
the Boykos, the Hutsuls,
these are the Ruthenians
from the extreme west of,
you know, what's now considered Ukraine.
Also in Czechoslovakia, also in Poland.
So she was a Lemko from
the far, far, far west
of what you'd think of
Ukrainian territory,
who moved to Odessa, became a communist.
And then she was in the West
Ukrainian Communist Party,
inside Poland in the interwar period.
So she was someone who
understood Ukrainian politics
from all the way from the west.
So why am I telling you all
this detail about Khrushchev?
Oh, Khrushchev was also
involved in the suppression
of Ukrainian partisans after
the Second World War, right?
So Khrushchev knew that there
was a Ukrainian question.
He knew there was a Ukraine,
he'd been deeply involved with it
in many angles for decades.
So it's a little bit,
it's a little bit like
after the First World War,
when the Bolsheviks realized, okay,
of course we have to deal
with Ukraine in some way
because we've just realized
Ukrainians can field an army
and, you know, they
lost, but they're real.
After the Second World War,
and Khrushchev comes to power
after Stalin's death which is 1953,
he is someone who's been dealing
with the Ukrainian question
one way or another, on
and off his entire life.
So he finds a solution to this question
of how Ukraine can both
exist and not exist.
Here's the solution.
It has to do with an anniversary, okay?
So imagine it's 1954
and Khrushchev has just come to power.
1954-
See, it's like so handy that
you've taken this class,
like, it goes back centuries, right?
Because you're immediately thinking 1954,
that's the 300th anniversary
of the Treaty of Pereiaslav, right?
That's what you're thinking.
You're like, you guys were right on that.
And so was Khrushchev.
So the official interpretation
which is given of Ukrainian history,
and this is clever and
it is very influential
and it has something to do with
the war that's going on now,
the official interpretation
which Khrushchev gives is,
yes, of course, Ukraine
exists, ancient history,
distinct nation, Cossacks, all of that.
But in 1654,
Ukrainians chose to forever
bind their own history
with that of Russia, right?
So they existed in order not to exist,
or they existed in order to
exist at a higher level, right?
Ukraine existed, but it flowed into Russia
and thereby exist at a higher level
as part of now the Soviet Union, right?
That's dialectical thinking.
If you kind of stretch your
neck a little bit, it's easier.
So this is kind of a brilliant solution
and it's connected with,
'cause it seems to solve
this ideological problem
the Soviet Union keeps having.
Ukraine is real, but then
like, we're afraid of it.
What are we gonna do?
What's its future?
Its future.
Its future was chosen in 1654,
exactly 300 years before.
The way this was done
marks a couple of trends
in the communist world.
The first I've already suggested,
which is this anniversary business, right?
The nostalgia,
the justifying things on the
basis of hundreds of years ago.
The second is consumerism.
So in 1954, to mark
this grand anniversary,
which they just, you know, invented.
I mean, it's not that
anybody was celebrating
the 100th or the 200th, right?
Only the 300th (chuckling)
was somehow important.
So they produced consumer
goods marked 300 years,
200,
200,000
I think it's Yekelchyk
who writes about this in your reading,
2 million packs of cigarettes
with 300 years written on them,
which is kind of mysterious.
It's like the opposite
of the health warning
you get now, right?
200 pairs of men's socks,
200,000 bras and nightgowns.
And I just like leave
it to your imagination
what impression it makes when
a bra says 300 years on it.
(audience laughing)
But I mean, in fairness,
this was the beginning
of consumerism in the Soviet Union.
Okay, the other thing
which happens in 1954,
and this is, again, very,
this is pregnant with
meaning for what comes next,
is that Khrushchev,
again, someone who understands
the Ukrainian question
and knows that, unlike a lot of,
you know, unlike Brezhnev
who's gonna come,
unlike other people,
he knows that it would make sense
to appear to be doing
something for Ukraine.
Khrushchev has the idea
that the Crimean Peninsula
will be transferred from
the Russian Federation
to Ukrainian Republic, right?
When I say Russian Federation,
I mean the Russian-
The RSFSR,
I mean the Russian Soviet
Socialist Republic,
the Russian Republic of the Soviet Union.
Trends because none of these
are independent states at the time.
Of course, there's a Russian
Republic, Ukraine Republic.
It's gonna be moved from
the Russian Republic
to the Ukrainian Republic.
Why did that happen in reality?
Two reasons.
The first is practical.
As you all know from reading the news,
Crimea is a peninsula, from
the point of view of Ukraine.
It's connected by land.
But it's an island, from
the point of view of Russia.
There's no connection to
Ukraine from Russia by land.
Hence the big bridge.
And so if you're going to,
so in terms of just sheer administration,
the connection of water
and electricity, the grid,
work much better from Ukraine
obviously then from Russia.
And so administratively,
it made a lot of sense.
The second reason why this
sort of thing was plausible
is the ethnic cleansing
of the Crimean Tatars.
Because up until 1944,
the reason why Crimea
had a special status,
it wasn't just in the Russian Federation,
it was an autonomous unit
of the Russian Federation,
because of the Crimean Tatars.
Once the Crimean Tatars
were ethnically cleansed,
as they were,
that reason for that status disappears.
In fact, that status itself
becomes a bit of an embarrassment.
Why was it an autonomous republic?
Because, you know, they're
not even supposed to speak
about the Crimean Tatars
at this point, right?
All the Crimean Tatar, like the toponyms,
just like Catherine did,
the toponyms, the place
names, are now being renamed.
Crimean Tatar war heroes are
being described as Dagestani.
They're being given other
ethnicities in Soviet press,
just because the idea
of the Crimean Tatars
is supposed to go away,
it's supposed to disappear.
And so that's another
reason why the transfer
of Crimea could seem plausible.
And it suggests a kind of,
look, it suggests two
interesting things at once.
That Ukraine is getting something,
so Ukraine should be grateful.
Russia is giving something.
But the idea that Russia
is giving something
suggests that it was
Russia's to give, right?
And here you find the
origin of this notion
that Crimea was always Russian.
Because how could Russia
have given it to Ukraine
if it hadn't been Russia's to give?
But maybe in some pretty profound senses,
it wasn't Russia's to give, right?
Maybe in some fairly profound senses,
Crimea had a diverse
history, all of its own.
Okay, so this moment in 1954
with the gift of Crimea,
the gift of Crimea from Russia to Ukraine,
you can see how that matters now.
Because the idea that
Crimea was always Russian
is based upon two things,
the ethnic cleansing
of the Crimean Tatars,
and then the idea that Russia
could give it to Ukraine, right?
That's the basis of that notion.
Okay, so.
But this from Khrushchev's point of view,
of course, this is a meant to be
a kind of pro Ukrainian gesture.
And towards the end of
Khrushchev's period,
we actually do move into
a period of something like
national communism in
the Ukrainian Republic
under a man called Petro Shelest.
Shelest.
I think I'll put his
name on there for you.
Shelest.
Shelest was a Ukrainian,
native of Ukraine.
Unlike Khrushchev,
he had nothing to do
with Stalinist crimes.
He was perceived as protective
of Ukrainian culture,
or at least not as interfering
with Ukrainian culture.
The 1960s saw a minor
renaissance of Ukrainian culture
led by young writers uncreatively known
as the Sixtiers group.
One of the figures here who's
gonna appear in a couple
of different junctures in
your reading is Ivan Dziuba
who wrote an interesting text called
"Internationalism or Russification?"
which raises the questions
which I've been talking about here
like, you know, for example,
well, it's about these tensions, right?
About how you handle Ukraine.
And is Moscow actually internationalist
or is Moscow actually Russifying?
Dziuba also in 1966,
and this is in your reading,
gives a little informal speech
at the site of Baby Yar.
Baby Yar is the largest
single massacre site
in the Holocaust in
terms of mass shootings.
In September of 1941, about
34,000 Jews were murdered
over the course of two days
over this ravine, Baby Yar,
at the edge of Kyiv.
And Ukrainian Jews, survivors, other Jews,
had been gathering
informally at this site.
And in 1966, Dziuba gave this
speech, which was, you know,
which was a kind of breakthrough
in Ukrainian-Jewish relations.
And that was all part of this
moment of relative freedom
of Ukrainian culture.
Okay, so Ukrainian history
came to an end, right?
You got it, 1654 Ukraine
merged into Russia.
Its only purpose was to merge into Russia.
You also get that that's not
really the end of history.
All right, so the third end of history,
I've already suggested,
is the end of Crimean history, right?
The end of Crimean history,
which is implied in this transfer.
You know, as you know in this class,
especially from that lecture
of a couple weeks ago,
actually a lot of the
oldest attested material
we have from this region is from Crimea
or from the southern coast.
The oldest attested peoples,
not the oldest peoples but
the oldest attested peoples
who left behind a written trace
are in or around Crimea,
and they're the Greeks and the Jews.
We know that the Golden
Horde and the Crimean Khanate
had a state in Crimea for about 600 years.
And that that came to an
end in 1783 when New Russia,
when Russian Empire takes over
and New Russia is declared.
At that time, the population of Crimea
was about 100% Crimean Tatar.
By 1944, it was 0% Crimean Tatar, right?
After the deportation.
And so, you know, as I mentioned before,
this is a kind of end of history.
Because it's not just that
the people are removed,
it is also that their
property is given away,
the names of sacred
sites, the names of towns,
the names of everything are changed.
The Crimeans are not only deported,
this might seem obvious,
but they're not allowed to come back.
And although Khrushchev generally
condemns Stalin's deportations of people,
he does not change the
rule that the Crimeans
are not allowed to come back.
And, of course, in this transfer of 1954,
this grand, you know, gesture
between Russia and Ukraine,
the Crimeans are totally absent.
Nobody goes to Uzbekistan
and asks the Crimeans
what they think about any of this, right?
And so this is a kind
of end of history too,
the end of the history of Crimea
or the end of history
of the Crimean Tatars.
And the notion that it was always Russia,
which, you know, has
its intellectual origins
around this 1954 transfer,
it also is very appealing
to Soviet citizens
who come to settle in
the Crimean Peninsula.
The Crimean Peninsula remains and becomes
a even more important Soviet naval base.
And so it has that demographic.
It also becomes a place where
Soviet notables can retire
for the very simple reason that it's warm
and most of the rest of Russia is not.
And when you're a recent arrival
in a colonizing position,
the notion that a place has
always been yours (chuckling)
is very attractive, right?
Very attractive.
See, look, you're getting
better at dialectics
all the time, right?
So like, precisely because you're new,
the idea that you've always
been there is very attractive.
Because the thought that
you're just there colonizing,
literally taking someone else's property
after they've been ethnically cleansed
is not very appealing.
So the idea that you were always there
is attractive precisely
because you weren't, right?
So that's the end of Crimean history.
Now the final end of
history that I wanna do,
actually there's two more,
the next one is the end
of Soviet history, okay?
And the end of Soviet history,
we're gonna talk more about
this in a lecture to come,
but the end of Soviet history
has to do with Brezhnev,
Leonid Brezhnev who
supplants Khrushchev in 1964.
He makes his debut on the
world stage really in 1968
when the Soviet Union and
its Warsaw Pact allies
invade Czechoslovakia to put to an end
a reform movement known
as the Prague Spring.
In 1968, he inaugurates what's
called the Brezhnev Doctrine.
The Brezhnev Doctrine is the idea,
and this has resonance today too,
that whenever a fellow socialist state
is threatened by counterrevolution,
the Soviet Union can arrive
with fraternal assistance, right?
So this metaphor of brothers
is a very interesting thing.
I mean, again, not to put
too fine a point on it,
but like being someone's brother
is not a very Marxist
idea, (chuckling) right?
At least not in this sense, right?
I mean, fraternite, okay,
that could be a revolutionary idea.
But the idea that I'm your big brother
and then when something goes wrong,
I get to come in and pound you,
that is not an especially Marxist idea.
And that's the idea of
brotherhood which is meant here.
And it also raises interesting questions.
Like, if you're my little brother,
who are the parents?
Like, where's mom and dad?
Like, where are they
in all of this? Right?
So like, this move into the family,
like it's actually a very
conservative move, right?
It's kinda mysterious, right?
There are just these brothers
and there aren't new sisters
and there aren't parents,
but there are brothers.
And the little brother's
always doing wrong
and the big brother's
always gonna come and help.
That idea in 1968,
but even more importantly
than that in 1968
about the Brezhnev Doctrine is that
it's no longer really about ideology.
So Brezhnev doesn't care about Marxism.
He cares about it much less
than we have in this lecture.
You know, Brezhnev, doing
that thing about dialectics,
he also would have like raised
his, you know, eyebrows,
which is more of an effort
for him than for you guys.
And, you know, would have said,
"Oh, what are you talking about" right?
Brezhnev was not interested
in Marxist theory at all.
The Brezhnev Doctrine is
not really about Marxism,
it's about power.
And the Brezhnev Doctrine defines what is,
as what should be, right?
So, you just follow the
line, whatever it might be,
and that's it.
We're not gonna justify
it theoretically anymore.
That's a big important
breakthrough in the 1970s
in the Soviet Union, and not only.
Because what it suggests is that
we are no longer moving into a future
where these dialectics
are still doing their work
or into a future where
Stalinist industrialization
is still producing dynamism
and economic change and social mobility,
which it did, for a couple generations.
But no longer.
Social mobility is
basically halted, right?
In the Soviet Union in the
1970s, if you're an engineer,
very likely your father
was an engineer, right?
If you went to university,
probably your parents did.
In the early days of the Soviet Union,
it wasn't like that, right?
It wasn't like that.
The nice apartments in
Kyiv, with all due respect,
like in the late Communist period,
they were owned by families
that were elite families.
Okay, owned is maybe the wrong word.
But in the early period, that wasn't true.
There was lots of dynamism
because of the economy,
but also because of Terror, right?
Also because of Terror.
One of the things, one of
the attractions of Terror,
if you're young,
I don't mean to give you ideas,
but one of the attractions of Terror
if you're young is that it-
Stop nodding in the front
row, it's troubling.
You're right like only a few feet from me.
One of the attractions of
Terror if you're young,
is that it clears up space above, right?
So the Great Terror of '37,
'38, among other things,
cleared up a lot of room up above
for people to move
through the ranks quickly
and make careers.
But both Khrushchev and Brezhnev,
and this is one of the few things
that Brezhnev kept from Khrushchev,
said we're no longer to have mass Terror,
at least that affects
other communists, right?
So that was another way that
social mobility was halted.
So what Brezhnev is doing in the 1970s
is he is proclaiming something like
what he calls really existing socialism.
And really existing
socialism, it's like that-
There's a Jack Nicholson movie
in which he says like, "This
is as good as it gets."
I've even forget the movie,
like maybe that was even the title,
but he is in a dentist's office
and he's like looking around.
It's like there was an old
guy sitting next to him.
He's like, "You know, this
is as good as it gets."
It's like that. Like, this is it.
Like, this is it. There's nothing else.
We told you there was gonna be communism,
there isn't gonna be communism.
This is it, right?
Your little apartment, you
know, whatever, that's it.
This is it. This is
real existing socialism.
This is what we've got.
And we're gonna defend it.
And it's not gonna change.
We'll keep it going, we'll
tinker with the economy,
but no major reforms,
certainly no theoretical discussion.
This is it.
And this has basic implications
for the Ukrainian issue
because, if everything is
just the way that it is,
all you gotta do is kind
of borrow from the West,
and this is how the Soviet
Union gets itself into trouble.
Talk about it next time.
But you borrow money from the West,
you borrow gadgets from the West,
you steal gadgets from the West,
you steal technology from
the West as best you can,
and you try to make the system,
as it is, function smoothly.
How does it function smoothly?
Suddenly Technocracy is what matters.
Not revolution, technocracy.
We all have to speak the same language.
What language is that gonna be? Russian.
And so here you have, you're
in this old imperial tension
where the center says,
I need you all to speak Russian.
But it's not because I don't
like, you know, Bashkir.
It's not because I don't like
be Belarusian or Estonian.
It's because it's efficient.
Whereas you, from your point of view,
in Mongolia or the Baltics or whatever,
you say, actually I kinda
like my own language
and I think it's plenty efficient.
You know, I think it works very well.
It's very efficient in my own life, right?
And so that tension, which is
built into all these projects
emerges in 1970s with
particular reference to Ukraine.
So Shelest is replaced in 1972
by Brezhnev's man who's
called Shcherbytsky.
And the 1970s then become a decade
of a kind of administrative
Russification of Ukraine.
No one says Ukraine doesn't exist,
no one says Ukraine high
culture doesn't exist,
but Ukrainian language
disappears slowly from schools,
the Ukrainian textbooks are
printed in far lower print runs.
It goes down to about 25%
by the end of the 1970s
of what it had been at the beginning.
Russian becomes very much
the language of prestige.
To take an example you
guys will understand,
everybody will understand this example.
You theoretically-
Okay, I'm just gonna put it to you, right?
Theoretically, you could
take your university exams
like the equivalent of your SAT, whatever,
university entrance exams in Ukraine,
you could theoretically take them
in both Ukrainian or Russian,
because we're tolerant, right?
But the difference is, if
you take them in Ukrainian,
you're not gonna pass.
(audience member laughing)
So what do you do, right?
I mean, what do you actually do, right?
So no one is saying Ukraine doesn't exist.
Look, here's the entrance exam, right?
Here, it's right there in front of you.
You wanna take it?
But if you want social advancement,
if you want to go to college,
you're gonna take it in Russian, right?
So that's the kind of dynamic
we're talking about here.
So I'm referring to this
as an end of history
because of this idea that
this is as good as it gets.
That, you know, everything
is now just about the-
It's about the consumerism.
You know, we're gonna kind of imitate
the capitalist that way.
We imitated them with the transformation,
now we're gonna imitate
them with consumerism.
And with the nationalism.
But this is where things get tricky.
In the '70s and '80s all
over the Soviet Bloc,
regimes begin to resort to nationalism.
But how do you do that
in the Soviet Union?
The Soviet Union's a multinational state.
The way that they do it is with nostalgia
about the Second World War,
which is referred to as
the Great Fatherland War.
When Brezhnev takes away the future,
he substitutes in the past, right?
He's actually very,
I mean, he gets mocked a lot
but these are very intelligent
political techniques
which plenty of capitalists
in the 21st century have copied, right?
So you take away the future
and you slide in the past.
And the past is a view of
the Great Fatherland War
in which the Soviet Union
is the innocent victim,
and the Soviet peoples defend the world
from the horrors of fascism,
led, of course, by the Russians.
So there's an ambiguity here.
Is it a myth about all the Soviet Union,
or is it a myth about Russia?
And it's in this myth
that present-day leaders
like Lukashenko in Belarus or
Putin in Russia were raised.
And it's another building
block in trying to understand
this war of 2022.
Because the idea of the Second
World War in which, you know,
Stalin's alliance with
Hitler is totally forgotten,
the Russians are totally
innocent and, you know,
won the war with nobody else's help,
you just have to simplify
that a few more steps
to get to the way Putin thinks
about the Second World War.
And also, it helps to explain,
you know, why he would think
that he could fight this war
the way that he has done.
You know, who is in fact-
The Mayor of Vienna, Karl Lueger,
who was an anti-Semite, he said,
you know, "Who is a Jew, I decide.
I decide who is a Jew," right?
Putin's notion is like, "Who
is a fascist, I decide," right?
If it's anybody but me.
Because by definition the
fascist are the other side.
And that's just a couple of
steps away from this view,
the Soviet view of the Second World War.
So it's an end of history
in which now you're
looking back to the past.
All right, where I wanna close
is just with a few minutes about Poland.
In Poland,
and here's where you get
all these funny names
that are at the end,
like all these names
of like Polish thinkers
and Ukrainian thinkers.
And the reason why they're here
is because in Poland,
or rather from Polish thinkers,
you get a very interesting moment
of Polish Ukrainian conversation,
which is actually about how
history's not over. (chuckling)
It's about how something new is coming
and we have to be ready for it.
Which is so different
and fresh in its time,
that many people can't
deal with it, right?
Even from the point of view of the West,
in the '70s and '80s,
the idea that there was gonna
be anything but more of this
was almost impossible to process, right?
By the '70s and '80s,
it really did seem like
Brezhnev was forever,
the Soviet Union was forever,
the Eastern Bloc was forever.
Ukraine had been pretty much
completely forgotten about,
except by the emigre institutions,
the Canadians in Alberta,
the Harvard Ukrainian Research
Institute, the diaspora.
But with the exception of that,
Ukraine was basically gone
from the Western imagination.
But there was a very interesting
project inside Poland
or among Poles which worked against this.
And it operated against this
notion that history was over,
which was also true in Poland too.
In Poland, there was
everything I talked about.
There was, 1968 as a turning point,
shift to consumerism and nationalism.
In the 1970s, the Polish
state actually declares itself
to be ethnically homogeneous,
which is a way of saying
history is over, right?
All these national things,
it's all Poles now.
No Jews, no Russians, no Ukrainians,
no Belarussians, no Germans.
It's just Poles and that's
the triumph of communism.
It's a very interesting version
of the triumph of communism, right?
But history is over.
There was a group of people
around a journal called "Paris Kultura."
And I need you guys to
know this name so much
that I'm going to give you
a hundred percent guarantee
that it's on the exam. (chuckling)
"Paris Kultura."
"Paris Kultura" was formed
by a group of Polish emigres.
Jerzy Giedroyc was the most important.
Juliusz Mieroszewski also very important.
Jozef Czapski.
And what "Kultura" said was,
about the Ukrainian question,
very interesting things.
But in 1952, they printed a
letter to the editor which said,
"Let Lvov be Ukraine."
Actually, it said,
"Let the blue and yellow
flag fly from Lvov."
Now if you're Ukrainian,
you're thinking like,
what's radical about that?
What's radical about that
is that Poland had just lost
half of its territory seven years ago
under conditions which could only be seen
as completely illegitimate, right?
The Soviet Union had taken
half of Poland's territory
in a war in which Poland had lost
millions of its own population, right?
In those conditions, saying,
"Oh yes, let's just like. Oh, fine."
You know, Poland only
had four major cities.
Warsaw was destroyed,
Vilnius went to Lithuania,
Lviv went to Ukraine, right?
And so you're saying, "Oh, legit."
It was like saying in 1952,
"Let the Ukrainians have it,"
was incredibly radical.
And they went from there to the argument
in the '60s and '70s-
Again, the crucial thing about this, guys,
the crucial thing is they
were thinking ahead, right?
They didn't think history was over.
They thought at some point
communism was gonna come to an end.
Even more essentially,
they thought that imperialism
had to come to an end.
And they didn't just mean
Russian imperialism, right?
They meant imperialism as a whole,
which meant their own imperialism,
their own Polish imperialism
had to come to an end.
So their strategic argument
for the existence of Ukraine was,
we need Ukraine because without Ukraine,
there will be Russian imperialism
and there will be Polish imperialism.
And both of those things are bad for us.
Russian imperialism bad for us,
Polish imperialism also bad for us.
So there was a calculated
strategic argument
which they made in the '60s and '70s,
totally in the wilderness.
Totally in the wilderness.
Other Polish immigrants
did not necessarily
go along with this view, right?
In the West, the idea that
communism have come to an end,
Ukraine, all this, pretty marginal.
But along with this,
and all these names that I don't have time
to mention anymore, unfortunately,
but along with this,
what "Kultura" did was
seek out and publish
exceptionally talented Ukrainian writers
like George Shevelov,
like Borys Levyts'kyi.
They found the Ukrainian writers
and they befriended them
and they published them.
The Ukrainian writers who
were executed in the '30s
or committed suicide,
the term Executed
Renaissance for those writers
comes from Jerzy Giedroyc.
He made that term up.
And he published a thousand-page book
collecting the works of these
Ukrainian writers, right?
No one else did that,
but "Kultura" did that.
And in this and many other ways,
they pushed Ukrainian
culture towards the center
of at least of Polish culture
and they made friendships.
I'm gonna finish now,
but you get the point.
By the time of Solidarity
in Poland in 1980,
the "Kultura," which was regarded
as the best Polish publication,
had already started this argument.
And so during the Solidarity
period in '80, '81
where there was some
space for free discussion,
the Ukrainian question
was already discussed.
And many leaders of Solidarity,
such as Adam Michnik and Jacek
Kuro issued statements
which were very friendly
to the idea of Ukrainian
independence during that period of '80-'81.
And then when Poland becomes
an independent state in 1989,
this argument has already been won.
And one of the first
things that Poland does
is that it begins a foreign policy
which is friendly to Ukraine.
Now the reason why any
of this was possible
was because this milieu of intellectuals
had been making this argument
that history was not over,
that communism was gonna come to an end,
that imperialism does
have to come to an end,
and we have to be ready for
it with arguments, right?
So, my plaidoyer here at the end
is one for the history of ideas.
And I'll explain more about
this in lectures to come,
but the fact that some people recognized
that history couldn't come to an end,
and that imperialism might come to an end,
actually had a great deal of influence
on how imperialism did
come to an end after 1989.
Okay, that's it.
Thanks.
(gentle music)